natural move is to defend the pawn  you've got a minute and a half left rook  f7 is such a weird move to find i only  found it because the computer is  shouting that move at me um  he's played it he's played it brilliant  magnus he's given up his queen already  for some pieces he tried to give up his  rook earlier now he's giving up his rook  for sure and  the pony actually you see on his face  he's kind of half smiling he knows this  game is going to go on forever now this  is a check and once the black king moves  it's going to move forward most likely  then the bishop drops and  what do we think good winning chances  for white this is a brook knight they  coordinate well and the pawns are  eventually going to move forward this is  the type of position where you just play  forever